okay stop me if you've heard this one
before an animated movie in which a
group of anthropomorphize objects goes
on a journey of self-discovery this is a
staple of Pixar movies what happens if
you take away pics are you add the kings
of stoner comedy and you give the movie
a hard R rating the pipes that are cause
you'd probably get sausage party a
raunchy 90-minute lark that might not be
great but it's definitely going to be a
dorm room classic for years to come no
one will believe you I have to dry Seth
Rogen who co-wrote the movie stars as a
hot dog named Frank yes who's thrilled
to finally be chosen by a supermarket
shopping due to a mishap though he and
his lady friend Brenda the bun voice by
Kristen Wiig have to journey far and
wide across the store in order to find
the answers they need it's hard to
imagine a movie that's more obviously
the product of a weed fuelled but man
what if the food knew it was getting
eaten man type of discussion and the
writers indulge their juvenile glee at
every possible turn there's weed smoking
and terrible puns and a truly filthy
food orgy and an unfortunate number of
cultural stereotypes and offensive
accents those accents notwithstanding
the boys cast is a stellar comedy
ensemble Rogen and wig are joined by
Nick Kroll and Bill Hader craig robinson
and Salma Hayek and michael cera Jonah
Hill Danny McBride Paul Rudd and the
list goes on
the writers are clearly going for
something here the movie is a not at all
veiled exploration of religion and the
thin line between faith and dogma but
too often it's undercut by easy
uncluttered gags there's a running riff
on israeli-palestinian strife starring a
bagel and a lavage get it there's a box
of grits that hates crackers get it the
taco is a lesbian do you get it movie
isn't nearly as edgy or transgressive as
it seems to think it is then again after
a couple of bong rips it might be
exactly with your sausage party hey I am
sorry I accidentally dropped a few
things back there ah I'm gonna fix you
I'm gonna fix this